hey guys today we're going to talk about
the best and worst dairy products okay
let's start over here the ideal
situation is to find 100% grass-fed
organic okay now they do have a
something new called truly grass-fed and
that's 95 percent grass-fed so that's
pretty good but when it says a hundred
percent it has to be I think 98 percent
not exactly 100 percent but it's close
now Organic means no pesticide no animal
by-products and you know that means it
means that they actually can put legally
waste product of another animal into the
feet and then we have something called
rbst this is a growth hormone now
Monsanto the company that sells this
will tell you that this is totally safe
there's no studies etc etc but then why
did Canada not allow this hormone since
2000 Europe they haven't allowed this
since 1990 and it's been banned in
Australia Japan Israel and Argentina but
only in America do we have the rBST so
we want to have our BST free dairy
ideally grass-fed organic ghee would be
really really healthy this is really
good for your gut it's a pure fat whole
cream make sure it's at least organic
half and a half organic but try to get
grass-fed the best cheese would be raw
goat's cheese or raw cheap cheese and of
course non-gmo but if you're doing
organic it's going to be non-gmo now you
can also do plain kefir of course
organic and grass-fed and this has a
much better friendly bacteria profile
than yogurt if you're gonna do yogurt
Greek yogurt is better because it has
more protein and less carbs but it still
has too many carbs if you're gonna do
keto
alright so now over here you have grain
fed okay I don't know if you realize
this but they will feed cows grains soy
and corn and they're usually GMO so
you're getting exposure to glyphosate
okay I would
not recommend commercial milk or
processed cheese commercial dairy
products usually have the rbst in there
okay there have antibiotics and animal
by-products and sometimes when you're
doing keto people really load up on the
dairy the problem is that many many
people have a casein allergy that's the
protein in the dairy and so they're
getting bloating they're getting all
sorts of issues and another big issue is
the lactose intolerance okay this is the
milk sugar because our bodies
stop making lactase the enzyme that
breaks down this milk sugar right around
like five years old
so we have very small amounts if any so
a lot of people get a lot of bloating
diarrhea when they consume milk products
it's not a true allergy it's just
blocking that enzyme and then when
you're going to the grocery store and
buying just regular yogurt that's
sweetened you're getting you massive
amounts of sugar and when you combine
that fat with that sugar it's not good
the only condition that you want to
consume a high-fat diet is when you're
doing a low-carb you never want to do
high carb with high fat or even high
carb with high protein and this is why
ice cream is even more deadlier because
they're putting so much fat and sugar at
the same time you're just gonna just
really spike the insulin and clog up
your arteries also some of the so-called
keto friendly ice creams out there still
have like 6 grams of sugar that's still
too high so you want this down to two or
or less a lot of people that are doing
the keto program are dairy-free and they
do very well because there is some
problems with very potentially
increasing the size of the prostate if
you're doing a lot of dairy especially
this type of dairy also people are
getting a lot of mucus reactions from
dairy so if you're gonna do dairy stick
over here and try to do small amounts
not large amounts all right I'll see you
guys later
so I want to thank you for being here
and watching my videos if you haven't
already subscribed go ahead and do so so
you can stay informed of future videos